my dad joined Starfleet because he  believed in it  I joined on a dare you joined to see if  you could live up to him  you spent all this time trying to be  your father  I'm not a wondering just what it means  to be you  it isn't uncommon you know it's easy to  get lost in the vastness of space  there's only yourself your ship and your  crew I really want to head back out  there huh  what the hell is this  they're boarding us  I know why you're here why we are all  here our captain will come to us mercy  will be the last thing on his mind  fear of death easy illogical  fear of death is what eats us alive  everyone who goes there he kills that's  how friends are there we can't just  leave him behind  should a jeeps touch your strength it's  a civic this I think you're under  estimating humanity hold on to something  hurt me the impossible  well at least I want dialog